c'est kid ninh il est intéressant une
maladresse quelque chose de très pur vous
ne pouvez pas le simuler il
y a des noms d'enfants James Dean je
veux faire un essai photo sur je suis sur un
acteur inconnu je suis Jimmy
dentisterie nous avons de superbes photos ou
quoi  tu vas me rendre célèbre je le
garantis est-ce
que vous voulez prendre un verre
quelque part il y a quelque chose dans le coin un
peu de changement dans la musique j'aime la photographie
et tout
Jimmy la partie de ça je ne vais même pas
envoyer ces photos à la vie un mec qui
regarde  ivre qui est votre chef d'un
nouveau mouvement mr.  les eaux vraiment derrière
vous Jimmy John Barrymore Douglas
Fairbanks Cagney ils suivent certaines
règles quand vous êtes Humphrey Bogart vous
pouvez rattraper certains amis vous devez
jouer au jeu encore quelques semaines continuez à
respirer
et à sourire quoi qu'il arrive
ne vous arrive pas  juste arriver par accident je
me perds et mes règles je ne veux pas me perdre
et toutes ces autres choses il n'est
pas fiable est le vase est un artiste un
artiste
Jésus Jimmy comment as-tu grandi ici maintenant
Jimmy très heureux de te revoir
nous sommes très fiers tu ne peux pas repartir les
mains vides
tu penses que la vie va changer leur
vie
ici pensant que je suis le sujet de
cette petite expédition
[Musique]
tout change si vite la photographie
dit la façon de dire le temps placage
opinion nous vivons dans l'espoir